I know you hung out with Daisy Ridley a
little bit was there any other Star Wars
legends that you've run into along this
journey we were shooting a sequence on
this platform and it was quite a sort of
complicated sequence and Gareth and I
and we're in you know deep discussion
and suddenly out of the corner of our
eyes we just saw Mark Hamill walking
towards us it was a bit sort of a like
aa moment because we've been watching
the Empire Strikes Back is inspiration
for rogue one why Empire versus the film
that directly follows world 1.0
logically broke one is very much
parent-child relationship and similar to
Empire Strikes Back it has a lot of
similar similar in tone I'd say tell me
about cassian know what's up with this
guy what separates him from maybe some
of the other rebels it's a guy that
he'll always make the right choice you
know they're always thinking of the
cause and the rebellion before anything
else it seems like he has a strong
relationship with Jin they approached
life in a similar way you know it's like
a mirror living your differences aside
and understanding that the strength
comes in numbers you know the and also
that this diversity these cultural and
racial diversity that makes them so rich
and powerful it's a good message for
today's world you know R is Bodhi now
this is an interesting character because
he was with the Empire and he defected
over the rebels and so how much do they
tell you about backstory for your
captain they don't dad she kind of let
you fill that in for yourself which is
kind of cool you know when you're
working in a world already has so many
parameters defined and you know the
fandom is so kind of like established as
well it's nice to have some breathing
room within that to make something your
own not improv in this movie really
surprising they let you they let you
guys improv from the Star Wars movie a
lot of it's in there surprisingly truly
surprisingly they give you enough
backstory you know based on all the star
war movies and the laws of being in
install wall but the same time you know
you start discovering different
different different
elements for each character because it
is a new character so can I have to
build his world our relationship we had
it back one story that we we are very
much aware of because we mean the film
starts where their relationship is at a
certain stage but there was something
before as well what's chronics read on
Darth Vader he doesn't seem very
intimidated by this guy is there no
human resources training on Darth Vader
over there well I think you'll discover
within the Empire there is always the
opportunity for rapid and sudden
promotion and equally rapid and fatal
demotion rogue one is the period I love
it's it's connecting to the original new
hope anything in that original trilogy
era I am just besotted with I mean it's
just like going back home to your
childhood you get completely immersed in
that world I think that's what's gonna
be special is people will feel like
they're a rebel and they're watching it
they are requesting a callsign its own
Road Road one
[Music]